All right, welcome to the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast, Discover Heal Grow. I am here with Corey Gamberg, who's the executive director of the Rocklin Recovery Treatment Centers. And we're going to talk about some ways that depth psychology and some of the more experiential and somatic medicine overlaps with 12 step in drug alcohol recovery. Corey, thank you so much for being with us today. Yeah, man, thanks for having me. So can you tell me a little bit about your role in Rockland?
好的，欢迎收听 Taproot Therapy Collective 播客《发现、疗愈、成长》。今天我邀请到了 Rocklin 康复治疗中心的执行董事 Corey Gamberg。我们将探讨深度心理学以及一些更具体验性和躯体疗法的方法，如何与药物和酒精康复中的“十二步法”相结合。Corey，非常感谢你今天能来。是的，伙计，谢谢你的邀请。那么，你能简单介绍一下你在 Rocklin 的角色吗？
I've seen your stuff on LinkedIn. I've enjoyed some of the things that you've posted. You're coming from a similar perspective to us at Taproot, same stuff we talk about on our podcast. So I'd really like to hear from you how you do that work and what that looks like. Yeah, thanks for responding to some of the posts. Some of it's a little daunting to post, I think.
我在领英上看过你的内容，很喜欢你发布的一些东西。你的视角和我们在 Taproot 的视角很相似，也是我们在播客中讨论的内容。所以我真的很想听听你是如何开展这项工作的，以及它是怎样的。是的，感谢你对一些帖子的回应。我觉得发布这些内容有时还是有点令人望而却步的。
I don't know, I love it. I was like, I'm off the wrong way for people sometimes but you got to get over that man Yeah, you gotta get over that and just throw it out there and can if you build it they will come, you know Yeah, and yeah, there's been a lot of good feedback within Rocklin, you know So I'm the executive director of the Rocklin recovery group So it kind of oversee multiple outpatient facilities that we have. We operate substance abuse and mental health treatment centers in Massachusetts. And I think over the course of the last five years or so, it's been a mission of ours at that company to try to be on the cutting edge of substance abuse treatment of kind of what's
我不知道，我喜欢它。我当时想，这有时可能不适合某些人，但你必须克服这一点，伙计。是的，你必须克服它，把它发布出来。如果你建立了它，他们就会来，你知道的。是的，Rocklin 内部有很多好的反馈。我是 Rocklin 康复小组的执行董事，所以我负责监督我们旗下的多家门诊机构。我们在马萨诸塞州运营药物滥用和心理健康治疗中心。我认为在过去五年左右的时间里，我们公司的使命一直是努力走在药物滥用治疗的前沿，探索接下来会发生什么。
coming next. I'm a big believer that, you know, just to jump right into the Jungian stuff, like, as far as individuation goes, everything individuates, you know, so as a person moves through individuation, so does phenomena. So, you know, the experience of addiction itself individuates the experience of recovery itself individuates. And, you know, you can kind of see that a lot of the example that I use for a lot of people is I'm a drug addict who comes from the OxyContin era of drug addicts and that's not really something that we see as much today as we did 15 years ago. Heroin and Fentanyl are very different.
我是一个坚定的信徒，你知道，直接进入荣格的理论，就个体化而言，万物皆在个体化。所以，当一个人经历个体化过程时，现象也是如此。因此，成瘾的体验本身在个体化，康复的体验本身也在个体化。你可以看到，我给很多人举的例子是，我是一个来自奥施康定（OxyContin）时代的瘾君子，这在今天并不像 15 年前那样常见。海洛因和芬太尼的情况非常不同。
In my area at the very least, the increase in people using different drugs like methamphetamine has increased and that's become something that 10 years ago you didn't see as much. So addiction is changing and the landscape is changing. And with that, we need to find new ways to meet that for recovery. And that's a big part of the work that we're trying to do at Rocklin, you know, where to from here sort of thing. Yeah. Can you say that? Because a lot of like what I wanted to do, it's interesting, like you never really lose the bad reputation from the people who are wanting to kind of criticize you for being forward thinking, even when research catches up with what you're doing. But when we
至少在我所在的地区，使用甲基苯丙胺等不同药物的人数有所增加，这在 10 年前并不常见。所以成瘾在改变，环境也在改变。随之而来的是，我们需要找到新的方法来应对康复需求。这是我们在 Rocklin 努力工作的重要组成部分，即“从这里出发”之类的东西。是的，你能说出来吗？因为我想要做的很多事情，很有趣，你永远无法摆脱那些想要批评你具有前瞻性的人给你的坏名声，即使研究已经赶上了你正在做的事情。但是当我们
opened, which was not that long ago, I mean, it was five years ago, you know, people kind of acted like I was crazy for doing brain spotting. Now brain spotting is like almost kind of ubiquitous in our area that even the EMDR practitioners have kind of switched over. But I'm seeing kind of the eating disorder world and the treatment, resistant trauma world and the addiction and recovery world change a lot and blow up and that doesn't necessarily mean that 12 step is discarded or gotten rid of, it just means that we have kind of new brain-based medicines, new understanding of neurology, new understanding of cultural and anthropological metaphors
开业时，那并不久远，也就是五年前，人们觉得我做“大脑定位”（Brainspotting）简直疯了。现在，大脑定位在我们的地区几乎无处不在，甚至连 EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）从业者都已经转向了它。但我看到饮食失调领域、难治性创伤领域以及成瘾和康复领域发生了很大变化并迅速发展，这并不意味着十二步法被抛弃或废除，只是意味着我们有了新的基于大脑的药物、对神经学的新理解、对文化和人类学隐喻的新理解，
that need to come into this thing to keep it alive, to keep it relevant. And can you say some things about what you're seeing about where the industry was that wasn't great, where the industry is going now, and maybe what the future of that looks like as, you know, because, you know, when you're a part of a business, part of that is staying relevant and meeting the need of what's happening, you know, you can't rest on your laurels in it, and it looks like you're very forward-thinking in what you do. you can't rest on your laurels and it looks like you're very forward thinking in what you do. Could you kind of talk about some of the strengths weaknesses of how we do that in America and the in the in the profit motive of healthcare? Yeah, definitely. I mean, I've I'm someone I've worked in treatment in one position or another probably since 2011 or so. And in that time as well, I've been a part of starting some nonprofits that, you know, assist family members through the experience of addiction. So I've seen a lot.
这些都需要引入到这个领域中，以保持它的活力和相关性。你能谈谈你所看到的行业过去不好的地方、现在的发展方向，以及未来可能的样子吗？因为当你身处商业中，部分工作就是保持相关性并满足正在发生的需求，你不能固步自封。你看起来在工作中非常有前瞻性。你能谈谈我们在美国开展这项工作的一些优势和劣势，以及医疗保健中的利润动机吗？是的，当然。我从 2011 年左右开始就在治疗领域工作。在那段时间里，我也参与创办了一些非营利组织，帮助家庭成员度过成瘾的经历。所以我见识过很多。
I think my experience has always been as a person in treatment, as a person working in treatment, has always been faced with, you know, traditional 12-step approaches, evidence-based practice, CBT, DBT. And that was kind of the bread and butter. evidence-based practice, CBT, DBT, and that was kind of the bread and butter. To your point, over years EMDR and different sorts of modalities have come into play. I think something that's really big right now is the IFS modality. I think a lot of people are taking to that. And interestingly enough, that's just, in my opinion, depth psychology with clinical language. So it's interesting to see as far as the question of where are know, so it's interesting to see
我认为我的经验一直是一个处于治疗中的人，一个在治疗领域工作的人，一直面临着传统的十二步法、循证实践、CBT（认知行为疗法）、DBT（辩证行为疗法）。这些曾经是核心。正如你所说，多年来，EMDR 和各种不同的模式开始发挥作用。我认为现在非常流行的是 IFS（内在家庭系统）模式。我认为很多人都接受了它。有趣的是，在我看来，这只是带有临床语言的深度心理学。所以，关于我们走向何方的问题，这很有趣。
as far as the question of where are we going, it's evident to me that we're going to a place that has more depth. We don't, we're not responding to kind of surface level, let's polish this up and get through this and move on. We're not responding to that anymore as a collective. Do you think there's cognitive and behavioral implications of like behavior is all that's relevant.
对我来说，很明显我们正在走向一个更有深度的地方。我们不再仅仅回应那种表面的、让我们粉饰太平并继续前进的东西。作为一个集体，我们不再对此做出回应。你认为这是否有认知和行为上的影响，比如行为就是一切相关的？
So as long as you're not doing drugs, you're good. As long as you're going to church, you're good. As long as you're lifting weights in the morning, you're good. As long as you're eating your broccoli, you're good. But not looking at how old is that part of you that wants to use, or how old is that part of you that doesn't feel understood? Where does it come from? Where is it in the body? Do you feel those like earlier kind of CBT take or attempts to fuse the 12 step
所以只要你不吸毒，你就很好。只要你去教堂，你就很好。只要你早上举重，你就很好。只要你吃西兰花，你就很好。但没有审视那个想要使用药物的你有多大，或者那个感觉不被理解的你有多大？它来自哪里？它在身体的哪个部位？你是否觉得那些早期的 CBT 尝试或将十二步法与 CBT 融合的尝试，
with CBT is sort of avoidant for the lack of a better word avoidant of a more whole or more threatening psychology to our system? I probably would, you know, I probably would. I think that even now I think that and this is a big part of the work that I'm doing on a personal level Recovery just has to be more than that, you know recovery just has to be more than the the Cessation of symptom and the change in behavior and not using you know
用缺乏更好的词来说，是在回避一种对我们系统而言更完整或更具威胁性的心理学？我可能会，你知道，我可能会。我认为即使是现在，这也是我在个人层面上所做工作的重要组成部分。康复必须不仅仅是那样，你知道，康复必须不仅仅是症状的停止和行为的改变以及不使用药物。
Because as someone in recovery for so long, obviously I've seen a lot of people who you know Do that sort of thing like go to church to the meetings, they live that way of life, but they're still struggling with all these underlying, more deeply rooted issues that just changing behavior doesn't touch. And then to that point, I think that then immediately a relapse or some sort of behavioral regression is immediately seen as a failure and in that mindset it just creates this very shame-based recovery world I think. Yeah. And again just to kind of go back to that previous question I think where we came from a place where it was it was much like that grounded in changing your behavior, just don't use. And now we're moving to this experience where I see people in their early twenties and you can't really speak to them from that sort of 12-step mountaintop, you know,
因为作为一个康复了这么久的人，我显然见过很多人，他们做那种事，去教堂参加会议，过那种生活方式，但他们仍然在与所有这些潜在的、更深层次的问题作斗争，而仅仅改变行为是无法触及的。说到这一点，我认为紧接着复发或某种行为倒退会被立即视为失败，在这种心态下，我认为这创造了一个非常基于羞耻感的康复世界。是的。再次回到之前的问题，我认为我们来自一个非常注重改变行为、仅仅是不使用药物的地方。而现在我们正在进入这样一个体验，我看到二十出头的人，你不能真的用那种十二步法的“山顶”视角与他们交谈，你知道，
this sort of idea of sit down and shut up and this is what you're going to do. This generation, this new generation of people suffering from addiction, it's just not responding to that because they're longing for something deeper. And you know, this even happened within my community where I would say Jung probably was a very unknown figure, minus his mention in the big book and some people's knowledge of him. He was the only one that responded to Bill W. I mean Bill W wrote seven people and Freud didn't write him back. You know, Jung was the one who kind of gave... You talk about Roland Hazard. Sorry?
那种“坐下闭嘴，这就是你要做的”的想法。这一代人，这一代遭受成瘾折磨的新一代人，他们对那种方式没有反应，因为他们渴望更深层的东西。你知道，这甚至发生在我自己的社区里，我会说荣格可能是一个非常不为人知的人物，除了他在《大书》（Big Book）中被提及以及一些人的了解之外。他是唯一一个回应比尔·W（Bill W.）的人。我的意思是比尔·W 写信给七个人，弗洛伊德没有回信。你知道，荣格是那个给予……你谈到了罗兰·哈扎德（Roland Hazard）。抱歉？
So the story with Jung and Aya, the story starts with that guy, this guy Roland Hazard, and he writes to Freud and he writes to Adler and those guys kind of, they don't respond to him at all. And Young is the last. Hey Cory. I think the video is frozen. I'm not sure if you can hear me. Oh dear. Okay. Technical difficulties. We will try and reconnect and
关于荣格和 AA 的故事，故事始于那个人，罗兰·哈扎德，他写信给弗洛伊德，也写信给阿德勒，那些人基本上没有回应他。而荣格是最后一个。嘿，Corey。我想视频卡住了。我不确定你是否能听到我说话。哦，天哪。好的。技术故障。我们将尝试重新连接并
go from there. Hey, Corey, I lost you for a minute and you froze. I lost audio. Can you hear me? Sorry, Matt. Yeah, I can hear you. Can you hear me? I'm so sorry. Let me we'll just keep recording and then I'll fuse those together If you want to just kind of go from the he writes Adler Um, I think that's the last thing that I got. I apologize. Um, no, no problem, dude So so yeah this guy rolling hazard He writes freud he writes adler and they both you know, don't respond and young is the last one he writes Adler, and they both don't respond. And Jung is the last one he writes, and Jung is the only one who responds, and he says, okay, man, if you can come out to Zurich, that's cool, I'll work with you. And they worked with each other for a year. And the story goes is
从那里继续。嘿，Corey，我刚才失去你了，你卡住了。我失去了音频。你能听到我吗？抱歉，Matt。是的，我能听到你。你能听到我吗？非常抱歉。让我们继续录音，然后我会把它们合并在一起。如果你想从“他写信给阿德勒”开始，我想那是最后我听到的内容。我道歉。没问题，伙计。所以，是的，这个叫罗兰·哈扎德的人，他写信给弗洛伊德，写信给阿德勒，他们都没有回应。荣格是最后一个他写信的人，荣格是唯一一个回应的人，他说，好吧，伙计，如果你能来苏黎世，那很好，我会和你一起工作。他们一起工作了一年。故事是这样的，
as soon as he left Zurich and got on the crane, he was drunk. And he calls Jung back or he contacts Jung, and there's this real humbling moment on Jung's part where he goes, okay, well, I kind of misdiagnosed you. I thought you were a hard drinker, but you're what people call a real alcoholic. And the only thing that's going to help you is some sort of spiritual experience or spiritual transformation, essentially. So go home and find that. And is that the letter where he says spiritus ex spiritum the replace spirits with spirit no that's so that's the letter he writes to Bill W okay and that's like that's that's kind of that's probably ten years past this story when that letter actually yeah that's the one I'm familiar with so I don't know the
他一离开苏黎世登上火车，他就喝醉了。他打电话给荣格，或者他联系了荣格，荣格有一个非常谦卑的时刻，他说，好吧，我有点误诊了你。我以为你是个酗酒者，但你是人们所说的真正的酒精成瘾者。唯一能帮助你的是某种精神体验或精神转变，本质上是这样。所以回家去寻找那个吧。那是他在信中说“spiritus ex spiritum”（以灵换灵）的那封信吗？不，那是他写给比尔·W 的信。那是故事发生十年后才有的信。那是那封我熟悉的信，所以我不知道
Roland-Hazard stuff yeah Roland-Hazard is kind of the guy who really helps the AA become AA because he comes back to the States, he joins the Oxford group, which is kind of its precursor. He gets sober through the Oxford group practices. He meets Abby Thatcher, who's Bill W's best friend. Abby Thatcher meets Bill W and the story goes. But without Young, we really don't have this idea that, you know, spirituality or some sort of spiritual experience is the answer or one of the solutions for addiction.
罗兰·哈扎德的事情。是的，罗兰·哈扎德是那个真正帮助 AA 成为 AA 的人，因为他回到美国后，加入了牛津小组（Oxford Group），那是它的前身。他通过牛津小组的实践变得清醒。他遇到了艾比·撒切尔（Abby Thatcher），那是比尔·W 最好的朋友。艾比·撒切尔遇到了比尔·W，故事就是这样。但如果没有荣格，我们真的不会有这种想法，即精神或某种精神体验是成瘾的答案或解决方案之一。
So it's just interesting that a lot of people aren't familiar with him or weren't familiar with him in the community that I was in. And then over the last probably seven or eight years, he's become prominent in a multitude of ways, not only in the recovery communities, I think, but also in the collective, which really speaks to something of greater depth as well. So to that point of when you're forward thinking, people kind of think you're crazy, but then eventually they catch on. That's kind of what happened with Young.
所以有趣的是，很多人并不熟悉他，或者在我所在的社区里不熟悉他。在过去七八年里，他在多个方面变得突出，不仅是在康复社区，我认为在集体中也是如此，这确实说明了一些更深层次的东西。所以，当你具有前瞻性时，人们会觉得你疯了，但最终他们会赶上来。这就是荣格身上发生的事情。
Even when we opened Rocklin and we started, you know, talking about Young, it wasn't something that even clients who were coming in for treatment were really familiar with. And it's introducing people to, you know, an entirely different perspective and way to move about psychological life. And, you know, to jump in some of the hard questions of AA or some of the sticking points people have with it when you say spiritual experience I mean do you mean that I have to see an angel do you mean that I have to go to church do
即使当我们开设 Rocklin 并开始谈论荣格时，即使是来接受治疗的客户也不是真的很熟悉他。这是向人们介绍一种完全不同的视角和心理生活方式。而且，要跳入 AA 的一些难题或人们对它的一些症结，当你提到“精神体验”时，我的意思是，我必须看到天使吗？我的意思是，我必须去教堂吗？
you mean I have to make contact with a deep part of myself I don't understand what do you what do you mean there you know that spirituality is essential for recovery could you speak to that? Yeah I mean I think it means so many different things to so many people. And beyond like spiritual experience, I really like what AA's text says about, you know, the psychic change and, and taking that from a psychological point of view and breaking it down etymologically, you know, we're looking for a soul perspective, a soul transformation. So the way that I see the world, so to me, you know, a spiritual experience is when something happens to me that has happened so many times yet I can experience it
你的意思是，我必须与我内心深处我不理解的部分建立联系吗？你到底是什么意思？你知道，精神性对康复至关重要，你能谈谈吗？是的，我的意思是，我认为这对不同的人意味着很多不同的事情。除了精神体验之外，我真的很喜欢 AA 的文本中关于“心理转变”的说法，从心理学的角度来看，并从词源学上进行分解，你知道，我们正在寻找一种灵魂的视角，一种灵魂的转变。所以，我看世界的方式，对我来说，精神体验是当某件事发生在我身上，虽然已经发生过很多次，但我可以
Perspectively and embody it in a totally different way. I don't react in my old behavior. I don't react in my own my old thinking. I'm able to see something happening to me and respond in a completely different way that allows me to find more meaning in that experience versus some sort of resolution to it. And I think that's something that's really hard for people in the treatment world to understand when they work with people is how to hold space for clients versus needing to offer them some sort of resolution to what they're bringing up. Because a lot of times it's just about putting some voice to the experience and getting some distance and perspective on it that shifts the way you relate to it.
从透视的角度去体验它，并以一种完全不同的方式去体现它。我不会用旧的行为去反应。我不会用旧的思维去反应。我能够看到发生在我身上的事情，并以一种完全不同的方式做出回应，这使我能够在那种体验中找到更多的意义，而不是寻求某种解决方案。我认为这是治疗领域的人在与人工作时很难理解的一点，即如何为客户保持空间，而不是需要为他们提供某种解决方案。因为很多时候，这只是关于为体验赋予声音，并获得一些距离和视角，从而改变你与它的关系。
Yeah, I talk about like why a lot of the stuff that is brain-based works. IFS is probably the most well-known kind of repackaging of some of those things Yeah, but I think the trick is the metacognition that these parts of self feel like they are possession Like they're all of us like they take over whether or not we admit that that's happening. You know that that's what's happening and then Repressing them through a cognitive or behavioral intervention or more avoidant intervention You just white knuckle it through life until you never,
是的，我谈论为什么很多基于大脑的东西有效。IFS 可能是这些东西中最著名的重新包装。是的，但我认为诀窍在于元认知，即这些自我的部分感觉它们是被占有的。就像它们就是我们全部一样，它们接管了我们，无论我们是否承认这就是正在发生的事情。你知道这就是正在发生的事情，然后通过认知或行为干预或更回避的干预来压抑它们，你只是咬牙切齿地度过一生，直到你从未，
even if you make it to the end of your life and that thing never does flare up and make you deal with the shadow or make you relapse, you're still taking that energy and avoiding it in a way that I think does damage. And what the metacognitive parts do is they let you experience that without being overwhelmed by it,
即使你活到了生命的尽头，那件事从未爆发让你去处理阴影或让你复发，你仍然在以一种我认为会造成损害的方式消耗能量并回避它。而元认知部分所做的是，它们让你在不被它淹没的情况下体验它，
without even having to identify with it directly you can have sympathy without over identification and and that those networks in the brain are attention they are at odds, but we we need all of them and Yeah, what these are doing are letting us know those parts of self without them possessing us essentially. Yeah, 100% I agree with that. Yeah, it's interesting because you know, IFS is growing like I saw that you had done some training at the Chicago Union Institute. Yeah, which is probably where 50% of our web has come from. Oh wow, nice. Yeah, which is even though we're in Alabama. Yeah, that in New York is like half, you know, a couple thousand a month, but the like, people get angry with me for saying that, you know, I like IFS, but that
甚至不需要直接认同它，你可以在没有过度认同的情况下产生同情，大脑中的那些网络是注意力，它们是不一致的，但我们需要它们全部。是的，这些正在做的是让我们在不被它们占有的情况下了解自我的那些部分。是的，100% 我同意这一点。是的，这很有趣，因为你知道，IFS 正在增长，我看到你在芝加哥荣格学院做过培训。是的，那可能就是我们 50% 的网络来源。哦，哇，不错。是的，即使我们在阿拉巴马州。是的，那和纽约一样，每个月有几千人，但是人们因为我说我喜欢 IFS 而对我生气，但
if you're going to do individual therapy, it may not be the best way to go to sink $15,000 into that because what Schwartz is doing a lot of that is putting Jung and the post Jungians together with Fritz Perls, the experiential stuff. And people will send me hate mail about that. And I'm like, man, this is in the introduction of his book like I haven't even gotten He's telling you you know like this is him But I don't know I mean I see it as like a model that takes a lot of these perennial philosophy and then trains people to do it and Facilities quickly, you know with a with a universalized language
如果你要进行个人治疗，投入 1.5 万美元可能不是最好的选择，因为 Schwartz 所做的很多事情是将荣格和后荣格学派与 Fritz Perls 的体验式东西结合起来。人们会给我发仇恨邮件。我说，伙计，这在他的书的引言里，我甚至还没开始读，他就在告诉你，你知道，这就是他。但我不知道，我的意思是，我把它看作是一个模型，它吸收了许多这些永恒的哲学，然后训练人们在机构中快速地使用它，你知道，使用一种普遍化的语言。
But without the amount of work that it takes to kind of learn a lot of these things that take, you know, 72 years to learn some of the time. I don't know if you could speak to that when you're saying like where the industry is going and kind of what's getting popular and why, you know. Yeah, I mean, I think that to me, you know, working with an individual in treatment or someone who's pursuing, you know, recovery or substance abuse treatment, it's a journey, man. It's an unfolding. To work with them, it can't be something quick. We can't do a quick fix.
但是没有学习很多这些东西所需要的努力，有时需要 72 年才能学到一些东西。我不知道你是否能谈谈这一点，当你谈到行业走向何方以及什么正在流行以及为什么时。是的，我的意思是，我认为对我来说，与治疗中的个人或追求康复或药物滥用治疗的人一起工作，这是一段旅程，伙计。这是一个展开的过程。与他们一起工作，不能是快速的东西。我们不能进行快速修复。
We have to take the time. I'm a very psychoanalytic thinker. Therapy is about the retelling of my story. I think that that's the area that we need to move the industry in is bringing people in to see that, you know, their struggle with addiction or their struggle with alcoholism is not some sort of moral failing. It is not something that makes them different from another person. It's a sole event. You know, addiction is this sort of Promethean rupture in the psyche, this desire to transcend and grab that fire and also feel divine in myself, to Jung's point.
我们必须花时间。我是一个非常精神分析的思考者。治疗是关于我故事的重述。我认为这是我们需要推动行业发展的领域，让人们看到，他们与成瘾的斗争或与酗酒的斗争不是某种道德上的失败。这不是让他们与众不同的东西。这是一个灵魂事件。你知道，成瘾是心灵中某种普罗米修斯式的破裂，这种超越并抓住那团火的渴望，同时也像荣格所说的那样，在自己身上感受到神性。
So I think that working with people one-on-one needs for the industry to really progress and survive and be useful in a big way. It needs to understand that the process is not a 30 day thing, it's not a 60 day thing that you might expect. But the research says that the recovery, could you speak to people that are thinking
所以我认为，为了让行业真正进步、生存并发挥巨大作用，与人一对一地工作需要理解这个过程不是 30 天的事情，也不是你可能预期的 60 天的事情。但是研究说康复，你能对比那些正在思考的人说些什么吗？
whatever comes after that ellipses? Usually the clinical psychology grad school student that has just taken their research 101 or 201 class and sends me hate mail. Could you tell them why that research isn't maybe not relevant as somebody who is an executive director and also in recovery? Yeah, I mean, I deal with this all the time where we'll hire clinicians that are 26 years old who get a master's degree and then they come out and they think everything is cookie cutter and this is how you work with someone and then you do this and then you do this and There's it's not touching anything. You know, it's not touching anything of the real wound of why this is happening
无论省略号后面是什么？通常是刚修完研究 101 或 201 课程并给我发仇恨邮件的临床心理学研究生。作为一名执行董事同时也是康复者，你能告诉他们为什么那些研究可能不相关吗？是的，我一直处理这个问题，我们会雇佣 26 岁的临床医生，他们获得了硕士学位，然后出来，他们认为一切都是千篇一律的，这就是你与人工作的方式，然后你做这个，然后你做那个，没有任何触及点。你知道，它没有触及任何关于为什么会发生这种情况的真正伤口。
You know to this idea that behind the behavior of addiction there is an image and the work really needs to become this would be there is an image and the work really needs to become this would be real Hillman piece of it but the word really needs to become identifying the images behind the behavior of addiction you know the images of descent the images of rupture the images of longing and exile and these are the things that then need to kind of be amplified in the individuals experience and revisioned into their mythos. And if they can do that, and that doesn't happen in four weeks, doesn't happen in six weeks, you know, that's a real down and dirty process.
你知道，这个想法是，在成瘾行为的背后有一个意象，工作真的需要变成——这会是真正的 Hillman 的部分——但工作真的需要变成识别成瘾行为背后的意象。你知道，坠落的意象、破裂的意象、渴望和流放的意象，这些是需要在个人体验中被放大并重构到他们的神话中的东西。如果他们能做到这一点，而且这不会在四周内发生，不会在六周内发生，你知道，这是一个真正深入和彻底的过程。
But when that happens, we have seen, especially at Rocklin, lasting recovery, but also recovery that looks totally different. You know, these are people that pursue the 12 step process, but understand it as a practice simply of grounding and a way to kind of organize and hold their suffering for a period of time, but not live there. And I think that's a big piece of where recovery is going in the future, where the industry needs to go in the future. AA and that 12 step model is great for that grounding experience
但是当这种情况发生时，我们已经看到，特别是在 Rocklin，持久的康复，但也看到了看起来完全不同的康复。你知道，这些人追求十二步法过程，但将其理解为仅仅是一种扎根的实践，一种在一段时间内组织和容纳他们痛苦的方式，而不是住在那里。我认为这是康复未来走向的一个重要部分，也是行业未来需要去的地方。AA 和那个十二步模型对于那种扎根体验来说很棒，
But it's not a place to live in and I think that's been the dominant mode of thinking for a lot of people in the addiction space Well, and one of the things that I think is Well, I'm trying to think of how I want to set that question up, but I'll just give you three pieces of something and then see how you want to fit them together. One of the things is I get a lot of calls of a certain type and I'll say, when I get somebody who's saying that they're having a dissociative disorder that is just flaring up all of a sudden and they don't know why and they're starting to drink alcohol more
但它不是一个居住的地方，我认为这在成瘾领域对很多人来说一直是主导的思维模式。好吧，我想的一件事是，好吧，我正在考虑如何提出这个问题，但我会给你三个部分，然后看看你想如何将它们组合在一起。其中一件事是我接到很多特定类型的电话，我会说，当我接到有人说他们有解离性障碍，突然爆发，他们不知道为什么，他们开始更多地饮酒，
or they're starting to have some kind of symptom more is y'all ask like, what age are your kids? Because so, and they're like, what? I'm like, you know, what happened to you when you were at that age? Because so much of the time it's like, if I'm a woman and I have a sexual assault or an abuse and then at seven and then my child is right about to be
或者他们开始有某种症状，我会问，你的孩子多大了？因为，他们会说，什么？我说，你知道，当你那个年纪时发生了什么？因为很多时候，如果我是一个女性，我在七岁时遭受了性侵犯或虐待，然后我的孩子正好要到
seven, especially if the child's female, your body starts to almost give you that thing to start to understand in order to protect your child. You know, I see that happen a lot. One of the things that happens with with addiction, I think, is people are like, man, everything's going good. Like I'm going to church, I've got this nonprofit, I'm doing this, I'm doing this, I'm doing this, but I'm like feeling this overwhelming, whatever. And you know, it was an alcoholic
七岁，特别是如果孩子是女性，你的身体几乎开始给你那种东西，让你开始理解，以便保护你的孩子。你知道，我经常看到这种情况发生。成瘾发生的一件事，我认为，是人们会说，伙计，一切都很顺利。我正在去教堂，我有这个非营利组织，我正在做这个，我正在做这个，但我感到这种压倒性的，无论什么。你知道，我曾经是一个酗酒者，
or I use, you know, IV drugs, but I've been in recovery and that's good and whatever. I always am like, how long have you been in? Was it about three years? Because it seems like that three year mark is where, you know, all of the technique and the skill and the cognitive parts of like how not to use drugs or how not to participate in the behavior that you're in recovery from or there and established. But then all of a sudden, there's this, the original problem that put you there is back, but you don't really want to go back to your old solution. But all of a sudden, the problem is a problem problem and you're trying to deal with it. And that's like where the real trauma work can start where like brain spotting and the Jungian lens of the soul
或者我使用静脉注射药物，但我一直在康复中，这很好，无论如何。我总是问，你康复多久了？是三年左右吗？因为似乎三年是一个标志，所有的技术、技能和认知部分，比如如何不使用药物或如何不参与你正在康复的行为，都在那里并建立了。但突然之间，把你带到那里的原始问题又回来了，但你真的不想回到你旧的解决方案。但突然之间，问题成了问题，你正在努力处理它。这就是真正的创伤工作可以开始的地方，像大脑定位和荣格的灵魂视角
is like such a helpful thing. And so that I love getting those phone calls because I know that person's just so ready, you know? Yeah. Can you say anything about that? Definitely. I mean, I think that that is so accurate. It's funny.
是如此有帮助的事情。所以我喜欢接到那些电话，因为我知道那个人已经准备好了，你知道？是的。你能对此说些什么吗？当然。我的意思是，我认为这非常准确。很有趣。
It's so funny because I usually think that it's around like this four to six year mark that that really starts to happen for people. So, you know, and I talk about that and that happened in my experience, you know, like, I believe that the 12 steps are, it's a mythology. And mythology is, can be thought of as a psychic container. You know what I mean? It holds our suffering. It gives our suffering context, it gives my suffering language, it gives my suffering ritual, and that's what being in AA does. And so for that three year period of being in AA, that four year period, you know, everything is able to be held within that mythology. And then that exact thing happens where you kind of take a step back and the formulaic aspect of what you've been
这太有趣了，因为我通常认为这大约是在四到六年的时候，这真的开始为人们发生。所以，你知道，我谈论这个，这在我的经历中也发生过，你知道，我相信十二步法是一个神话。神话可以被认为是心理容器。你知道我的意思吗？它容纳我们的痛苦。它给我们的痛苦提供背景，它给我的痛苦提供语言，它给我的痛苦提供仪式，这就是在 AA 中的意义。所以在那三年的 AA 期间，那四年的期间，你知道，一切都能够被容纳在那个神话中。然后那件事发生了，你退后一步，你一直在做的公式化的方面
doing and the rigidity of what you've been doing, it starts to confine and something in you is trying to grow beyond that. And we don't have places for those people to go that don't want to return to use, but also can admit that what they've been doing really isn't working anymore. And a lot of times, especially in the 12 step community, it's kind of met with dismissal, you know, like, oh, you're overthinking it, you know, maybe your ego's getting in the way or, oh, you're heading towards a relapse. And how frustrating is that? Because for someone who's done quote unquote, done the work
以及你一直在做的僵化，它开始限制，你内心有什么东西正试图超越它。我们没有地方让那些不想回到使用药物，但也承认他们一直在做的事情真的不再起作用的人去。很多时候，特别是在十二步社区，它会被拒绝，你知道，比如，哦，你想多了，你知道，也许你的自我阻碍了你，或者，哦，你正走向复发。这有多令人沮丧？因为对于一个已经完成了所谓的“工作”，
and changed behaviors and changed thought patterns and going through all of this stuff, they're simply saying, I can't identify with that mythology anymore. And so I need to find the next container. And the work that I've been doing, I really categorize this period of recovery as post-recovery work.
改变了行为和思维模式并经历了所有这些事情的人来说，他们只是在说，我无法再认同那个神话了。所以我需要找到下一个容器。我一直在做的工作，我真的把这段康复期归类为“后康复工作”。
It's not walking away from recovery, but it's changing the way we understand it, to your point. It's moving away from formula and rigidness, and it's moving into more of trying to deeply understand the roots of the problem in the first place. Now that I've had some time away and I've stabilized, I can do that work. And a lot of I've had this experience where a lot of friends of mine will go five, six, seven years. And you know, then all of a sudden they're out and they're relapsing and you ask them what happened. And a lot of them said they felt this way
这不是远离康复，而是改变我们理解它的方式，正如你所说。它正在远离公式和僵化，并转向更多地试图深入理解问题的根源。现在我有了一些时间，我已经稳定下来了，我可以做那项工作。我有很多朋友会经历五、六年、七年。然后突然之间他们出去了，他们复发了，你问他们发生了什么。他们中的很多人说他们有这种感觉，
but they couldn't speak to it. They didn't feel like they had someone who was gonna be there to hold that because it was gonna be met with some sort of aspect of or experience of that dismissal. And what's frustrating is a lot of those people are not saying they want to relapse. They're not having any kind of desire for that. And it's almost like the community pushes them that way because they need to
但他们无法说出来。他们觉得没有人会在那里容纳这种感觉，因为它会遇到某种拒绝的体验。令人沮丧的是，这些人中的许多人并不是说他们想复发。他们没有任何那种欲望。这几乎就像社区把他们推向那个方向，因为他们需要
interpret everything as this need to use again. And so that becomes the language that they're almost offering somebody. And I think the fusion of 12-step and the Jungian thing, it's not either or, it's, you know, making a bigger container, you know? And every, every epic, every cultural cycle, we have to do that because the culture is different, the addiction is different, the drugs are different, the cultural factors that make up the human psyche and the waters we're swimming in are different.
把一切都解释为再次使用的需要。所以这成了他们几乎提供给某人的语言。我认为十二步法和荣格理论的融合，不是非此即彼，而是，你知道，制造一个更大的容器，你知道？每一个时代，每一个文化周期，我们都必须这样做，因为文化不同，成瘾不同，药物不同，构成人类心灵的文化因素和我们游泳的水域也不同。
So of course, these methods have to change. And the idea that, well, this was randomized controlled trial, so it's a hundred percent. If you do this, you have the best odds. I don't really believe that that is a dynamic of a model of research and clinical practices as we need. Absolutely. And it's just the same thing.
所以当然，这些方法必须改变。那种认为“好吧，这是随机对照试验，所以它是百分之百的。如果你这样做，你有最好的几率”的想法，我不认为那是研究和临床实践模型的动态，我们需要那种动态。绝对是。这完全是一回事。
I mean, you know, I think about Hillman's book a lot. You know, we've had a hundred years of psychotherapy and the world is getting worse. And, you know, I think about that in relation to AA sometimes. I wouldn't say that it's getting worse, but we've had 100 years of AA almost. Where are we going now? And is it still meeting the times?
我的意思是，你知道，我经常想到 Hillman 的书。你知道，我们已经有了一百年的心理治疗，而世界正在变得更糟。而且，你知道，我有时会想到 AA。我不会说它正在变得更糟，但我们已经有了近 100 年的 AA。我们现在要去哪里？它还在满足时代的需求吗？
And to your point, its language works for what it works for, but then it starts to fall short. And again, to your point, how many people have we lost trying to fit themselves into that container once they outgrew it? Yeah, that's bad thing to think about yeah, and I think outgrowing it doesn't mean that you can drink or use drugs You know Occasionally or I mean it doesn't have to mean when a lot of the people who are scared by this kind of thing means It means that the small continues to to mean what a lot of the people who are scared by this kind of thing means. It means that the soul continues to grow. And a lot of times there's no plan to ever use again.
正如你所说，它的语言在它有效的地方有效，但随后它开始显得不足。再次正如你所说，有多少人在他们超越了那个容器后，试图把自己塞进去而失去了？是的，那是一个糟糕的想法，是的，我认为超越它并不意味着你可以喝酒或使用药物，你知道，偶尔，或者我的意思是，它不必意味着当很多被这种事情吓到的人意味着什么时。它意味着灵魂继续成长。很多时候，根本没有计划再次使用。
There's, it's not a good idea to ever go back to partial recreational use of anything. That isn't the distinction. You know, it is that there is a bigger model where we can continue to have containers for people that are in further and further along. You've written a lot about James Hillman, who was a... I guess he was a Jungian analyst, even though he got out of Zurich with fire and later said, I'm not an analyst, I'm not
这不是一个好主意，永远不要回到任何东西的部分娱乐性使用。那不是区别。你知道，它是有一个更大的模型，我们可以继续为那些走得越来越远的人提供容器。你写了很多关于 James Hillman 的文章，他是一个……我想他是一位荣格分析师，尽管他带着火离开了苏黎世，后来在德克萨斯州被解雇时说，我不是分析师，我不是
a clinical psychologist when he was being fired in Texas. I don't know what to call him, but he was an interesting guy. He was a good writer. Can you talk about how Hillman's kind of imaginal archetypal psychology informs some of what you do or just his ideas? Yeah, definitely. And real quick, I just want to say to that other point, I think part of the goal of recovery is to have that growth experience. You know, it is to move on eventually and not stay put. So, just to end that question, you know. Hillman, to me, is kind of like my psychological forefather. It's really wild. I just, I stumbled upon his work for the first time probably in around 2017 or so. I picked up
临床心理学家。我不知道该怎么称呼他，但他是一个有趣的人。他是一个很好的作家。你能谈谈 Hillman 的意象原型心理学是如何影响你所做的一些事情，或者仅仅是他的想法吗？是的，当然。很快，我只想对比那一点说，我认为康复的目标之一是拥有那种成长的体验。你知道，它是最终继续前进，而不是停滞不前。所以，只是结束那个问题，你知道。Hillman 对我来说就像我的心理学先祖。这真的很疯狂。我第一次偶然发现他的作品是在 2017 年左右。我拿起了
The Soul's Code. I really wasn't in a place to read it, you know, how that happens with books, you know, you psyche picks it up, but it's not really the right time. And it wasn't until probably more closer to COVID and the 2020 timeframe where I had downloaded the volume of his biography, the first one by Dick Russell, and I walked around my apartment complex every day listening to it. And the more and more I listened to it, it's just so much related to my experience within the Recovery Collective. He kind of came into the Jungian world, and then as he progressed through it, he kind of found the same juncture that we're speaking of. This is the
《灵魂密码》（The Soul's Code）。我真的不在一个能读它的状态，你知道书是怎么回事，你知道，你的心灵拿起了它，但它真的不是合适的时间。直到更接近 COVID 和 2020 年的时间框架，我下载了 Dick Russell 写的他的传记的第一卷，我每天在我的公寓大楼里走来走去听它。我听得越多，它就越与我在康复集体中的经历相关。他进入了荣格的世界，然后随着他的进步，他发现了我们正在谈论的同样的交汇点。这是
old way, and it's kind of cracking cracking and what's going to come next. I think that Hillman opened so many doors for people in this current climate. You know, I think he was a man ahead of his time and I think his time is coming and his time is probably, you know, now in some fashion because again, we're hungry for new perspectives and new ways to think and the way that he talks about returning soul to psychology and soul as a perspective, soul as something you can kind of embody, not some sort of thing that you have.
旧的方式，它正在破裂，接下来会发生什么。我认为 Hillman 为当前气候下的人们打开了许多扇门。你知道，我认为他是一个超越时代的人，我认为他的时代正在到来，他的时代可能，你知道，现在以某种方式到来，因为再次，我们渴望新的视角和新的思考方式，他谈论将灵魂带回心理学以及灵魂作为一种视角，灵魂作为你可以体现的东西，而不是你拥有的某种东西的方式。
It's a way of saying- It's like the soul being different. John Beebe would point out about Hillman too, that they're not the same thing. Yeah. Maybe some overlap. Yeah. And so, you know, for me, I think bringing some of Hillman's ideas into the addiction space started for me. It's kind of funny, like, you know, and in revisioning psychology has this chapter
这是一种说法——就像灵魂是不同的。John Beebe 也会指出关于 Hillman 的一点，它们不是同一回事。是的。也许有一些重叠。是的。所以，你知道，对我来说，我认为将 Hillman 的一些想法引入成瘾空间对我来说开始了。这很有趣，就像，你知道，在《重构心理学》（Revisioning Psychology）中有这一章
about, you know, basically this process of seeing through, seeing through something into its archetypal roots. And that's kind of what happened. His work led me to look deeper through the recovery experience and beyond that kind of, again, try to conceptualize this next phase of what recovery is for people when they outgrow that initial container. And it's helped me to sort of bring mythopoetics into the addiction space and allow people to understand the addiction process as initiation but also as a living myth for them. It's part of their story and you know do this with introducing certain stories like Prometheus or Persephone and Tantalus
关于，你知道，基本上是看穿的过程，看穿某事进入其原型根源。这就是发生的事情。他的作品引导我更深入地审视康复体验，并超越那种，再次，试图概念化当人们超越了最初的容器时，康复的下一个阶段是什么。它帮助我将神话诗学引入成瘾空间，并让人们将成瘾过程理解为启蒙，但也作为他们的一种活的神话。这是他们故事的一部分，你知道，通过引入某些故事，如普罗米修斯、珀耳塞福涅和坦塔罗斯来做到这一点。
and again just finding these new containers for people to conceptualize their suffering through beyond a clinical model or some sort of research you know. Yeah. Yeah, I, Homan is an interesting figure to me and because he's one that I couldn't get away from like I kept bumping up against. A lot of him, I think, is not quite finished. You know, like a lot of the things that he puts out as finished works, he was more in the process of something than he was willing to admit. I've talked to Dick Russell on here, his biographer.
再次强调，我们要为人们寻找新的容器，让他们在临床模式或某种研究之外去构思自己的痛苦。是的。是的，希尔曼对我来说是一个有趣的人物，因为他是我无法摆脱的人，我不断地与他碰撞。我认为他身上有很多东西还没有完成。你知道，就像他作为成品发布的东西一样，他其实处于某种过程中，而不是他愿意承认的那样。我在这里和他的传记作者迪克·拉塞尔谈过。
Hopefully we're gonna talk to him again later this year when his next book is coming out. I've talked to David Tacey, who is an analysis and and a assistant element. He's an admirer of a lot of his work and also a critic of a lot of his work. I've talked to Lawrence Hellman, who is James Hellman's son, um, and, and also working in astrology and psychology, um, and, and uh, industrial organizational psychology too. Um, and he was somebody who I kept seeing my own worst angels in,
希望今年晚些时候他的下一本书出版时，我们能再次与他交谈。我采访过大卫·塔西，他是一位分析师，也是一位辅助元素。他是希尔曼许多作品的崇拜者，也是他许多作品的批评者。我还采访过詹姆斯·希尔曼的儿子劳伦斯·希尔曼，他也在从事占星学和心理学，还有工业组织心理学。他是我不断看到自己内心最阴暗面的人，
like the part of myself that I was kind of afraid of. Because I think that there was a element of Hillman that was kind of driven mad, a little madness he mastered later in life, but by his ability to see through time beyond his own life and the inability for his whole life to contain the expansiveness. You know, we all kind of hit that. And that the reason that I mentioned that is not to opine on helmet a ton, but I think a ton of recovery work that is embodying that is soulful, that is good. Is helping people come to terms with these frustrating and impossible limitations of life that are human.
就像我内心深处某种让我感到害怕的部分。因为我认为希尔曼身上有一种让人疯狂的元素，一种他在晚年掌握的疯狂，但他有能力看穿时间，超越自己的生命，而他的一生又无法容纳这种广阔。你知道，我们都会遇到这种情况。我提到这一点并不是为了对希尔曼发表太多意见，但我认为大量的康复工作如果体现了这种灵魂，那就是好的。它正在帮助人们接受生活中这些令人沮丧且无法避免的局限性，这些局限性是人类所共有的。
The body, um, the temporal thing that we have to to sit through. I'm thinking of Simone Vey, the mystic, that says, well you should approach an addict like somebody who is trying to eat God. That this person is, you know, sort of trying to contain all of it in a way that isn't possible and to really reconnect and know that it's not a taking in, it's an emptying yourself of to really make room for something else. Could you say anything about that? I mean, that's kind of a very open statement. Yeah.
身体，我们必须经历的这种时间性的东西。我想到了神秘主义者西蒙娜·薇依，她说，你应该像对待一个试图吃掉上帝的人一样对待瘾君子。这个人，你知道，试图以一种不可能的方式容纳这一切，并真正重新连接，知道这不是一种摄取，而是一种清空自己，从而真正为其他事物腾出空间。你能对此说点什么吗？我的意思是，这是一个非常开放的陈述。是的。
I mean, I think I would agree that Hillman had this way of seeing through the events in his life that made his grounded life, his literal life, a little chaotic for sure. And, uh, I think that. In my experience, it really opened up not necessarily kind of my darker sides of my life, but Hillman really opened me up to see how expansive my life could be or how expansive I was as an individual and coming from such a kind of structured recovery experience and world, that was really freeing to me. But I agree in the sense that it's hard to start with something like that, you know,
我的意思是，我同意希尔曼有一种看穿他生活中事件的方式，这确实让他的现实生活，他的字面生活，变得有点混乱。而且，我认为，根据我的经验，它并没有真正打开我生活中黑暗的一面，但希尔曼确实让我看到了我的生活可以有多么广阔，或者作为一个个体我是多么广阔。从那种结构化的康复经验和世界中走出来，这对我来说真的很自由。但我同意，从这样的事情开始是很难的，你知道，
that someone who's looking to get sober, really coming off the streets or right off of a run, it's really hard to grasp any of this imaginal, sort of deeper rooted material. But I think what's really important that I do with people in the early stages with them in relation to Hillman is really trying to kind of talk about the idea of pathology and this idea that we psychopathologize everything. I've listened to some of your episodes where you guys talked about evidence-based research and it's just you know, we psychopathologize everything and I had this instance with my son who you know, One day was just kind of pulling at his ears a lot, you know, and and I was with someone and they said something and I said, well, maybe he's just going to be a musician You know, maybe there's something like peculiar about the way he's listening and and we don't know rhythm of it Yeah, yeah
对于一个想要戒酒的人来说，刚从街上下来或者刚结束一段酗酒期，真的很难理解这些想象的、更深层次的材料。但我认为，我在早期阶段与人们讨论希尔曼时，非常重要的一点是，真正尝试谈论病理学的概念，以及我们对一切事物进行病理化处理的这种想法。我听过你们的一些节目，你们谈论过循证研究，你知道，我们对一切事物都进行病理化处理。我儿子有一次，你知道，有一天他一直在拉他的耳朵，你知道，我和某人在一起，他们说了些什么，我说，也许他只是要成为一名音乐家。你知道，也许他听东西的方式有些特别，我们不知道其中的节奏。是的，是的。
We don't need to say that there's something wrong But we need to try and honor this thing that's happening and and I talk about that with like people's experience of depression a lot you know if you when you experience depression from a You know, if you, when you experience depression from a Hillman's perspective, I would say, if you kind of work with it a little bit and embody the depression a little bit, you realize certain things like when you're depressed, you watch different movies, you eat different food, you listen to different music, and you might dress differently. And through that experience with depression, you're able to gain a perspective through
我们不需要说有什么问题，但我们需要尝试尊重正在发生的事情。我经常和人们谈论他们对抑郁症的体验，你知道，如果你从希尔曼的角度去体验抑郁症，我会说，如果你稍微处理一下它，并稍微体现一下这种抑郁，你会意识到某些事情，比如当你抑郁时，你会看不同的电影，吃不同的食物，听不同的音乐，你可能会穿不同的衣服。通过这种抑郁的体验，你能够通过那个镜头获得一种视角，而这种视角是你之前无法通过自我（ego）的视角获得的。
that lens that you weren't able to gain a perspective through that lens that you weren't able to gain through your ego's perspective prior. And in that way, the depression is actually a gift. It's actually the soul trying to tell you something. And if you break down that word, psycho, sorry, psyche logo, psychopathology, or psychopathos, that is the love of the soul.
从这个意义上说，抑郁实际上是一份礼物。它实际上是灵魂试图告诉你一些事情。如果你拆解“心理病理学”（psychopathology）这个词，即“灵魂的爱”（psyche logo, psychopathos）。
And so, you know, a symptom like depression is the soul's way of loving us into seeing something about our lives that we cannot see from ego consciousness. And, and that, you know, understanding that is very freeing from this idea that there's something wrong with me. Yeah. And I think that is so important for people to understand. And that's why I think Illman's time is sort of coming because I think people are ready for something like that versus this idea that I'm sick and I need to get on this medication and I need to do this for the rest of my life.
所以，你知道，像抑郁症这样的症状是灵魂爱我们的方式，让我们看到一些我们无法从自我意识中看到的生活真相。理解这一点，能让人从“我有问题”的想法中解脱出来。是的。我认为这对人们来说非常重要。这就是为什么我认为希尔曼的时代即将到来，因为我认为人们已经准备好接受这样的东西，而不是那种“我病了，我需要吃药，我余生都需要这样做”的想法。
Yeah. And also I think seeing a static end goal as this place that we get to is always gonna let you down. The other issue I have with the biomedical model is that like you're saying, it turns every symptom into a problem or into a not even a problem as much as a finite thing. And I think that you should get under it
是的。而且我也认为，将静态的最终目标视为我们到达的地方总是会让你失望。我对生物医学模型的另一个问题是，就像你说的，它把每一个症状都变成了一个问题，或者说不是一个问题，而是一个有限的东西。我认为你应该深入它，
and see it as a dynamic force that is sometimes good, sometimes bad, but always you and a part of yourself that you can learn to hold. And that when we turn things into an objective metric, like, you know, we can look at a white cell blood count in a hard science like biology, but we can't really do that with psychology, like a lot of the people that want to turn us into a computer or just an inevitable result of computational genes are trying to do. We need to be able to see these things as the soul speaking, the soul crying out, as dimension, you know, you don't even have to kind of do trans-dimensional forces, but just dynamic forces that need to be understood. And ultimately can probably only be understood by, you know, the person who is, who is the one having the soul that is an analysis, you know.
并将其视为一种动态的力量，有时是好的，有时是坏的，但它始终是你自己的一部分，你可以学会掌控它。当我们把事物变成客观指标时，比如，我们可以在生物学这样的硬科学中观察白细胞计数，但我们不能在心理学中真正做到这一点，就像许多想把我们变成计算机或计算基因的必然结果的人试图做的那样。我们需要能够将这些事物视为灵魂的诉说，灵魂的呼喊，作为维度，你知道，你甚至不需要去搞跨维度力量，只需要理解那些动态力量。最终，可能只有那个拥有这个灵魂的人，也就是正在进行分析的人，才能真正理解它。
There is a rhythm to suffering. And I think that's such a thing that I talk about with people in recovery, which is this idea that you're in this process now and you're sober and you're helping other people and you're showing up. It by no means means that you're not going to suffer. Like heartbreak is going to happen, relationships are going to end, jobs are going to end. And it kind of follows this rhythm of Persephone.
痛苦是有节奏的。我认为这是我在康复过程中经常与人们谈论的事情，即你现在处于这个过程中，你已经清醒了，你在帮助别人，你在展现自己。这绝不意味着你不会受苦。心碎会发生，关系会结束，工作会结束。它遵循着珀耳塞福涅的节奏。
The idea is you're always going to return to the underworld and we're all going to return to the underworld and we need we need to learn how to move through the underworld without grasping for the fruits and the fruits for people in recovery or drug addicts are relief and comfort and all these things. So we need to learn how to maneuver the underworld in a participatory way, not in a defensive way. I think that's another thing that Hillman really brought out in me that changed my life, which was I need to participate with my emotions, not defend myself against them. And that really opened up a whole world for me
这个想法是，你总是会回到冥界，我们所有人都会回到冥界，我们需要学习如何在不贪恋果实的情况下穿过冥界，而对于康复中的人或吸毒者来说，这些果实就是解脱和舒适。所以我们需要学习以一种参与的方式，而不是防御的方式来操纵冥界。我认为这是希尔曼带给我的另一件事，它改变了我的生活，那就是我需要参与我的情绪，而不是防御它们。这真的为我打开了一个全新的世界。
Yeah, I have you read all three volumes of Hillman's biography. Are you I've read I haven't read I have like psychotically. Yeah. Yeah Dick Russell when I interviewed it wasn't out yet He said that there was kind of a forgiveness of Jung when Hillman found the red book and that a lot of the anger That he had he kind of let forgiveness of Jung when Hillman found the Red Book and that a lot of the anger that he had, he kind of let go of because he saw that as this descent and return that he was wanting psychology to have. And he saw that Jung had done that himself to kind of have the framework that he later built.
是的，你读过希尔曼传记的所有三卷吗？我读过……我没有读过……我读过，像精神病一样。是的，是的。迪克·拉塞尔在我采访他时，书还没出来。他说，当希尔曼发现《红书》时，他对荣格有一种宽恕，他所怀有的许多愤怒，他都放下了，因为他看到了这正是他希望心理学所拥有的那种下降与回归。他看到荣格自己也做到了这一点，从而拥有了他后来建立的框架。
He just didn't think that the kind of archetypal realm that he was descending into with the Red Book was something everyone needed to do. It was something he wanted to glean insights from and then inform his writing. But Jung had this idea of descent and return, which, you know, Campbell takes and makes the hero's journey for, you know, pop psychology
他只是不认为他通过《红书》下降到的那种原型领域是每个人都需要去的地方。那是他想要从中汲取见解，然后为他的写作提供信息的地方。但荣格有这种下降与回归的想法，你知道，坎贝尔将其拿走并将其变成了英雄之旅，用于流行心理学，
and screenwriters, but there's this idea of like, you know, that you go down into this place that is the descent into hell or the descent into the underworld, or ultimately the parts of yourself you don't understand, and then you come back. but that you do that enough that the ego kind of becomes porous to where it's unafraid of it.
和编剧，但有这样一种想法，你知道，你进入这个地方，即下降到地狱，或者下降到冥界，或者最终是你自己不理解的部分，然后你回来。但你做得足够多，以至于自我变得多孔，不再害怕它。
And it's not a rigid boundary that just cracks and becomes psychotic or just needs to crack and dissociate or crack or lose itself in addiction. But that it becomes this porous boundary like a cell wall that can let unconscious contents in. But it's still a filter, it's still there. We have to have that individual identity, we have to have that ability to turn off a lot of ourself
它不是一个只会破裂并变得精神错乱，或者需要破裂并解离，或者在成瘾中迷失自己的僵硬边界。它变成了一个像细胞壁一样的多孔边界，可以容纳无意识的内容。但它仍然是一个过滤器，它仍然在那里。我们必须拥有那种个体身份，我们必须拥有关闭我们自己的很大一部分的能力，
because we can't just be this expansive ball of energy of all we are. Could you say some about maybe that reforming the process? Because I think the biggest risk I see when somebody is telling me that they've Finished with addiction work or something is that they view it as a destination where they're done and they used to feel this way And they won't feel that again and it's no on a certain level. You'll always feel that way It's being able to go down and descend into that and then learn something from it without using
因为我们不能只是成为我们所是的所有能量的扩张球。你能谈谈重塑这个过程吗？因为我认为当有人告诉我他们已经完成了成瘾工作时，我看到的最大风险是他们将其视为一个终点，他们已经完成了，他们过去有这种感觉，而他们不会再有这种感觉了，这不对。在某种程度上，你总是会有那种感觉。这是能够深入其中，然后从中学习，而不使用，
And without ultimately doing anything that is turning you off or being Destructive, you know, yeah, and I think that's kind of what I meant with the example of depression without using and without ultimately doing anything that is turning you off or being destructive. Yeah, and I think that's kind of what I meant with the example of depression. It takes a period of time before you can participate with something like that in that manner. And I think that's really the process of that initial period of recovery.
并且最终不做任何让你关闭或具有破坏性的事情，你知道，是的，我想这就是我用抑郁症的例子所表达的意思。在以那种方式参与某事之前，需要一段时间。我认为这确实是康复初期阶段的过程。
It's helping the ego gain enough strength to be able to do something like that. And I think that's an immensely important piece of the work. People who are jumping into the descent or archetypal or Jungian work too soon, they risk that idea that the ego isn't strong enough to hold the contents that they meet or that arise. But I think to your point, that's what I meant with the idea of depression. We have to go into it and not be afraid of it
它正在帮助自我获得足够的力量来做这样的事情。我认为这是工作中极其重要的一部分。过早跳入下降或原型或荣格工作的人，他们冒着自我不足以容纳他们所遇到或出现的内容的风险。但我认为，就你的观点而言，这就是我所说的抑郁症的意思。我们必须进入它，不要害怕它，
and kind of see that the more and more I have that experience, one of the ways I think about it metaphorically is when I assign to depression that it's mine, it gets sort of trapped in the body. and that's when we experience what I think collectively we understand as depression, you know, when I, when this phenomena arises and it comes to me for whatever reason, if I immediately trap it and I say, well, my depression has gotten really bad. I can't come to work today.
并看到我拥有这种体验的次数越多，我隐喻地思考它的方式之一就是，当我把抑郁症归为“我的”时，它就会被困在身体里。这就是我们集体理解的抑郁症，你知道，当这种现象出现，无论出于什么原因来到我身边时，如果我立即困住它，我说，好吧，我的抑郁症变得非常严重。我今天不能去上班了。
It actually exasperates the experience of depression. If the phenomena comes to me and I realize this is something visiting, there's a purpose for this happening and I work with it for a little bit and I do some writing and maybe I like I said, watch some movies or eat different food or whatever, dress differently or listen to different music, and I get to some resolve of what the depression was trying to get me to see, the phenomena I feel like leaves, you know? And then I find myself, all right, I'm okay again. I came out of that. I've risen up again from this experience. And now the next time it comes,
这实际上加剧了抑郁的体验。如果这种现象来到我身边，我意识到这是某种来访的东西，这发生是有目的的，我稍微处理一下它，我做一些写作，也许像我说的，看一些电影或吃不同的食物，或者穿不同的衣服，或者听不同的音乐，我得到了一些关于抑郁症试图让我看到什么的解决办法，我觉得这种现象就离开了，你知道？然后我发现自己，好吧，我又好了。我走出了那个困境。我又从这种体验中升华了。现在它下次再来时，
I have to do the same thing because it's going to come again. And it coming again does not mean failure, and it doesn't mean regression. And it just means, honestly, it just means we're human. It just means we're alive, that these phenomena, these psychic phenomena that you can't see, that you can't grasp, they come when they're ready. And like Hillman's point, behind every symptom there is a God almost. So what God is coming to me right now and why. So the question that people always direct at the Jungians
我必须做同样的事情，因为它会再次到来。它再次到来并不意味着失败，也不意味着倒退。老实说，这只意味着我们是人类。这只意味着我们还活着，这些现象，这些你看不见、抓不住的心理现象，它们在准备好时就会到来。就像希尔曼的观点，每一个症状背后几乎都有一个上帝。那么现在是什么上帝来到我身边，为什么。所以人们总是向荣格派提出的问题，
to start to put a head on some of this stuff is technique. You're talking about a map, you're talking about a process, you're talking about throwing the baby out with the bathwater of research and clinical psychology and the biomedical model. What do you want to do? What does recovery look like? Because I think for most people that have your perspective, the actual 12 step model doesn't really need to change that much. It just needs to prepare for where we're not white, knuckling it through the early stages of not using and kind of point towards another doorway. What does that door look like and what's on the other side
为了给这些东西定性，就是技术。你在谈论一张地图，你在谈论一个过程，你在谈论把研究、临床心理学和生物医学模型的洗澡水和婴儿一起倒掉。你想做什么？康复是什么样子的？因为我认为对于大多数有你这种观点的人来说，实际的12步模型并不需要改变太多。它只需要为我们没有在不使用药物的早期阶段咬牙坚持的地方做好准备，并指向另一扇门。那扇门是什么样子的，门后有什么，
and how do we build that? How do we do that? How do you do that through your work? Yeah, I mean, I think one of the big pieces about that is like, you know, I kind of feel like Hillman would call it the aesthetic response. Part of it is starting to have these little moments where you try to find the beauty in what's right in front of you and appreciate what's in front of you and see it as alive.
我们如何建立它？我们如何做到这一点？你通过你的工作是如何做到的？是的，我的意思是，我认为其中一个重要的部分是，你知道，我有点觉得希尔曼会称之为审美反应。部分原因是开始有这些小瞬间，你试图在你面前的事物中找到美，欣赏你面前的事物，并将其视为活生生的。
So you start to take more concern about the way you keep your home. You start to take more concern about the way you keep your home. You start to take more concern about the way you decorate your office. You start to take more concern about the way you're eating and the food you're eating. And love what he says about office spaces. If you go into your office and it's bright fluorescent lights and there's nothing on the walls and it's all white, there's no healing that's going to happen there. Or even when he talks about working with a married couple, he would say, let's not even talk about your marriage, but tell me how you decorate the living room.
所以你开始更多地关注你保持家园的方式。你开始更多地关注你装饰办公室的方式。你开始更多地关注你的饮食和你吃的食物。他关于办公空间的说法我很喜欢。如果你走进你的办公室，那里有明亮的荧光灯，墙上什么都没有，全是白色的，那里不会发生任何治愈。或者当他谈论与已婚夫妇一起工作时，他会说，我们甚至不要谈论你们的婚姻，但告诉我你是如何装饰客厅的。
And if there's just trash everywhere and everything is chaotic, then that's affecting you just as much. So I think part of what we need to do in recovery is return to some aesthetic appreciation of being able to see the beauty in the world and that it's affecting us just as much as we're affecting it.
如果到处都是垃圾，一切都很混乱，那么这对你的影响也同样大。所以我认为我们在康复中需要做的一部分是回归到某种审美欣赏，能够看到世界的美，并且它对我们的影响和我们对它的影响一样大。
Yeah, it's funny you mentioned the fluorescent lighting. One of the first episodes, I talked to the architect Leon Kreer about new urbanism, his work with urbanism. And at the time, I didn't even know that was going to be a podcast or that I would do one. And I was kind of wrestling with Hillman because there were parts of him that I really liked and there were parts of him that kind of scared me
是的，你提到荧光灯很有趣。在最初的几集里，我和建筑师莱昂·克里尔谈论了新城市主义，他关于城市主义的工作。当时，我甚至不知道那会是一个播客，或者我会做一个。我当时在和希尔曼较劲，因为他身上有些部分我真的很喜欢，有些部分让我感到害怕，
about myself. And Kreer, off my, like at our conversation at the end was like, oh yeah, you remind me of this guy that I met in Zurich when you're talking about that. Cause he didn't know Jung, but I probably said a Jungian idea or something. He was like James Hillman. I was like, oh, and he was like, yeah, he told me
关于我自己。克里尔在我们的谈话结束时说，哦，是的，当你谈论那个时，你让我想起了我在苏黎世遇到的一个人。因为他不认识荣格，但我可能说了一个荣格的想法或什么。他说那是詹姆斯·希尔曼。我说，哦，他说，是的，他告诉我，
that American architecture, like European architecture draws the eye upward. Everything is pulling you up because it wants you to contemplate God. But Americans come in and they put a drop ceiling in fluorescent lighting because capitalism needs you to stare down into hell. So.
美国建筑，就像欧洲建筑一样，吸引人们向上看。一切都在把你往上拉，因为它想让你沉思上帝。但美国人进来，他们安装了吊顶和荧光灯，因为资本主义需要你盯着地狱看。所以。
That's why it's best. I don't think Hillman ever wrote that, or at least I don't have never seen a recording of him saying that, but he did tell it to career in Zurich and at one point. That's amazing. That's amazing. And I but I do think that's that's so much of it right like Hillman would say to that recovery I think Hillman would say recovery is so immensely bound in monotheism and the perspective of Christianity, and it really is from the 12-step perspective, you know? And the idea is all about, you know, kind of transcending. You know, I transcend resentment. I transcend behaviors.
这就是为什么它是最好的。我不认为希尔曼写过那个，或者至少我从来没有见过他那样说的录音，但他确实在苏黎世告诉过克里尔。这太棒了。这太棒了。但我确实认为这在很大程度上就是这样，对吧？希尔曼会说康复，我认为希尔曼会说康复在很大程度上与一神论和基督教的视角紧密相连，从12步的角度来看确实如此，你知道？这个想法完全是关于，你知道，某种超越。你知道，我超越了怨恨。我超越了行为。
And I get above that. And I don't act like that anymore. And I reach purity. And that's just, you know, I think to the point we were talking about earlier, that sort of perspective or that sort of myth doesn't hold for forever. And, and we need to prepare people for for the fall of that and the ability to kind of go down and hold things soulfully and hold things from a sort of perspective of depth versus transcendence. Well and even somebody like Hillman who was just obsessed with bringing back a polytheism into psychology and wanted a return to the Greek mystery cults and getting away from monotheism. I don't think he saw monotheism or a singular self as a problem. He saw them as containers and that sometimes you need this type of container at different points of the
我超越了那些，我不再那样做了。我达到了纯洁。那只是，你知道，我认为对于我们之前谈到的观点，那种视角或那种神话并不能永远持续下去。我们需要让人们为它的崩塌做好准备，并有能力以灵魂的方式去下降和持有事物，并从一种深度而非超越的视角去持有事物。好吧，即使是像希尔曼这样痴迷于将多神论带回心理学，并希望回归希腊神秘崇拜，远离一神论的人。我不认为他把一神论或单一自我视为一个问题。他把它们视为容器，有时你在旅程的不同点需要这种类型的容器，
journey and other times you need this type of container. And then there were places where that top-down traditional hierarchy, you know, putting every, putting, you know, God into one box instead of lots of little boxes, or the divine, the self into one box instead of lots of little boxes was not allowing for a greater ritual to happen. You know, like if you go and you look at,
而在其他时候你需要那种类型的容器。有些地方，那种自上而下的传统等级制度，你知道，把上帝放进一个盒子里而不是许多小盒子里，或者把神性、自我放进一个盒子里而不是许多小盒子里，并没有让更大的仪式发生。你知道，如果你去看，
there's lots of places where I think Eddinger, Edward Eddinger puts Jung better than Jung puts himself because he wasn't quite settled with what he was trying to say. And Hillman's the same where it's like, he kind of opened up a conversation where there's some things where, I don't know that he ever said them perfectly
有很多地方我认为埃丁格，爱德华·埃丁格比荣格本人更好地表达了荣格，因为他对自己试图说的话并不完全确定。希尔曼也是一样，他开启了一场对话，有些事情，我不知道他是否在生命结束时完美地表达了它们，
by the end of his life, or at least not, you know, in a book. Maybe he was saying that to somebody else. But if you look at the through lines and what he's calling to come back into recovery, to come back into psychology, I think are an animism and a sense of ritual. An animism in that I can turn my own ego down enough to hear the world talk to me,
或者至少，你知道，在书中没有。也许他是在对别人说。但如果你看看主线，看看他呼吁回归康复、回归心理学的东西，我认为是万物有灵论和仪式感。万物有灵论在于，我可以把自己的自我调低到足以听到世界与我交谈，
to let my house be alive, to let the sword that I'm making be alive. You're turning down your own identity enough to hear the identity of the world and reinstalling that. In a way, you're never going to get there through an objective science that's going to say, this is the reason why you don't light the planet on fire.
让我的房子活起来，让我正在制造的剑活起来。你调低了自己的身份，足以听到世界的身份并重新安装它。在某种程度上，你永远无法通过一门客观科学达到这一点，它会说，这就是为什么你不应该点燃地球的原因。
This is the reason why Black Rock and hedge funds are probably the wrong path. Because a spreadsheet can't do that in a way that a re-ensulment of the world through animism can. Yeah. Same thing with ritual, you know. I think that's interesting. Like, I was only going to interrupt, but it was making me think.
这就是为什么贝莱德和对冲基金可能走错了路的原因。因为电子表格无法做到这一点，而通过万物有灵论对世界进行重新灵魂化可以做到。是的。仪式也是一样，你知道。我认为这很有趣。就像，我本来只想打断一下，但这让我思考。
Are you familiar with the work of Robert Sardello? Yeah, I've encountered him a little bit. So you know, that's sort of really Robert Sardllo's practices and some of his sort of contemplative work was really the segue for me into that ability to experience that sort of animism again. And this idea of getting out of that top down response from a phenomenological perspective and basis. And it's funny that they did a lot of work together
你熟悉罗伯特·萨德洛的作品吗？是的，我遇到过他一点。所以你知道，那确实是罗伯特·萨德洛的实践，他的一些沉思工作确实是我进入那种再次体验万物有灵论的能力的过渡。以及从现象学视角和基础出发，摆脱那种自上而下的反应的想法。有趣的是，他们做了很多工作，
when they were in Dallas at the Dallas Institute for Humanities and a lot of You know to your point about Ed and Jerry and young a lot of what sardello is doing is sort of taking Hillman and putting It in a more kind of structured context of more Maybe I don't know about academic but more Refined Way almost he definitely was gonna play politics with institutions way more academic, but more refined way almost. He definitely was going to play politics with institutions way more than Hillman ever was going to.
当他们在达拉斯人文学院时，你知道，关于埃丁格和荣格，萨德洛所做的大部分工作是把希尔曼放在一个更结构化的背景下，也许我不知道是不是学术性的，但更精致的方式。他绝对会比希尔曼更愿意在机构中玩弄政治。
Yeah. Yeah. I'm going to carry any water for anything that he didn't have complete respect for. And I think, I think too, with Hillman, like the idea of what you said about the self, you know, I don't think he was against the self. I think he was against the Jungian community making the self this goal to reach through analysis.
是的。是的。我不会为任何他没有完全尊重的东西背书。而且我认为，我也认为，对于希尔曼，就像你说的关于自我的想法，你知道，我不认为他反对自我。我认为他反对荣格社区把自我变成通过分析达到的目标。
Like you go into analysis, you individually and you reach the self and that's, you know, Edinger sort of, you know, ego self access. And that I think makes a lot of sense. But again, to that experience of rhythm, I just think you come in and out of that. You know, you experience the self and then you move around and you mess up and then you come back and you work with the self and that sort of more spirallic way of being in the world is much more, I feel like how Hillman honored the self versus those traditional Jungians as sort of like this end game.
就像你进入分析，你个人，你达到了自我，那就是，你知道，埃丁格的自我-自我轴。我认为这很有道理。但同样，对于节奏的体验，我只是认为你进进出出。你知道，你体验了自我，然后你四处走动，你搞砸了，然后你回来，你与自我一起工作，那种更螺旋式的生活方式，我觉得希尔曼比那些传统荣格派更尊重自我，而不是把它当作某种终局。
He definitely hated the literalism of the instit's that just takes over in the 80s and And I think probably rightly so I mean the people that I like left the Institute to that point to pursue an experiential and a Somatic medicine like Arnie Mendel with process therapy or Sidger and Halston with voice dialogue, which in some ways Is a more intuitive form of IFS I think and how sound with voice dialogue, which in some ways is a more intuitive form of IFS, I think. Yeah. And I think that Hillman's experience, again, like we were saying at the beginning, kind of his experience in Zurich really mimics what we're saying about the recovery experience,
他绝对讨厌80年代接管机构的字面主义，我认为这可能是对的。我的意思是，我喜欢的人离开了研究所，去追求一种体验式和躯体医学，比如阿尼·明德尔的流程疗法，或者西格和哈尔斯顿的语音对话，这在某种程度上是一种更直观的IFS形式，我认为。是的。而且我认为希尔曼的经验，就像我们开头说的那样，他在苏黎世的经验确实模仿了我们所说的康复经验，
you know, like, and it kind of comes up against to like, you know, with Hillman, the Pu'erh Senex work is so vast and it's such an intricate part of his thinking and that's sort of what we're up against you know like when the Cenex becomes two-one-sided in this rigid formulaic repetitious approach to recovery you know it breeds that poor shadow that needs to kind of just run out and jump out the window or you know kind of jump up and scream I'm not gonna do this I'm gonna go find something now yeah we need to honor that impulsivity as creative energy that the Cenex has kind of been pressing down, you know, and, and that was what he was up against in that period of time when he was sort of director of studies and trying to bring these new things to the Institute. Like,
你知道，它有点像，你知道，对于希尔曼，普尔-塞内克斯（Puer-Senex）的工作非常广泛，这是他思想中错综复杂的一部分，这正是我们所面临的，你知道，当塞内克斯在康复的这种僵化、公式化、重复的方法中变得过于片面时，你知道，它滋生了那种需要跑出去跳出窗外的阴影，或者你知道，跳起来尖叫“我不干了，我现在要去找点别的东西”。是的，我们需要尊重这种冲动作为创造性能量，塞内克斯一直在压制它，你知道，这就是他在担任研究主任并试图将这些新事物带入研究所时所面临的情况。比如，
what's that story in the first volume about playing softball? You know, like he he started bringing baseball gloves and softball and he would, you know, say and this was so crazy, he would say that, you know, they would have better discussions there than in any sort of lecture hall. And then I was in Chicago at a weekend teaching with an analyst named Dennis Merritt. And one of the first things he said was, you and he would say that in that softball, Eros was there. And from that platonic standpoint, you need Eros to teach anything. And so how can we look at that in the 12 steps is I would say that AA has lost its level of Eros. There's not enough anymore.
第一卷里关于打垒球的故事是什么？你知道，他开始带棒球手套和垒球，他会，你知道，说，这太疯狂了，他会说，你知道，他们在那里进行的讨论比在任何演讲厅里都要好。然后我在芝加哥参加一个周末教学，和一位名叫丹尼斯·梅里特的分析师在一起。他说的第一件事就是，他会说在垒球中，爱欲（Eros）就在那里。从柏拉图的观点来看，你需要爱欲来教授任何东西。所以我们如何看待12步中的这一点，我会说AA已经失去了它的爱欲水平。不再足够了。
And so the teachings start to lack. The communities start to become hierarchical. They start to become, well, that's that guy. He sponsors all these people, or this is the old timer who's been here for 20 years. Let's listen to him. They don't have that experience of Eros anymore. And I think that's what at his best he was trying to bring out and show people. And you know, I think it kind of backfired on him in a couple of ways, but, um,
所以教导开始缺乏。社区开始变得等级森严。他们开始变得，好吧，那是那个人。他赞助了所有这些人，或者这是在这里待了20年的老手。让我们听听他的。他们不再有那种爱欲的体验了。我认为这就是他尽其所能试图带出来并向人们展示的东西。你知道，我认为这在某种程度上对他产生了反作用，但是，嗯，
well when you're having an affair with a patient You might have too much eros in your psychoanalysis, you know Perfect guy. I mean it also the ethics was not modern You know, there are a lot of it wasn't like he's doing that today But yeah, there were a lot of things that are pretty wild in his biography You know and in his life, you know, and I think he would be the first one to tell you that Oh, definitely. Definitely.
好吧，当你和病人有染时，你的心理分析中可能有太多的爱欲，你知道。完美的人。我的意思是，伦理也不是现代的，你知道，有很多，并不是说他今天在做那个，但是的，他的传记中有很多相当狂野的事情，你知道，在他的生活中，你知道，我认为他会是第一个告诉你的人。哦，绝对，绝对。
Yeah, I wonder, you know, we talk about animism being, you know, the re-enchantment of the world, but to me, ritual is where you willfully and intentionally take parts of yourself that you wanna change externally, you externalize them, you know, in Western esoteric magic, that maybe is through burying a duck egg or putting these little figures on a board. But in art therapy, it's through art and hypnosis.
是的，我想知道，你知道，我们谈论万物有灵论是世界的重新着迷，但对我来说，仪式是你故意和有意地把你想要改变的自己的一部分外化，你外化它们，你知道，在西方深奥的魔法中，那可能是通过埋葬鸭蛋或把这些小人偶放在板子上。但在艺术治疗中，它是通过艺术和催眠。
It's through, you know, or guided meditation. It's through turning these pieces of you into an image. Then the important part of the ritual is modifying this image externally so that you have more power over those pieces of self and then reclaiming them. And I think that that ritual and animism are two of the things that Hillman wanted to come back a lot of his take on a polytheistic psychology is trying to do that. Could you say anything about those things in your work or how they show up, how you kind of use them if you do it all? Yeah, I mean, it's hard to say specifically. I'm trying to think if we, you know,
它是通过，你知道，或引导冥想。它是通过把这些你的碎片变成一个图像。然后仪式的重要部分是在外部修改这个图像，这样你对这些自我碎片就有更多的控制权，然后收回它们。我认为仪式和万物有灵论是希尔曼想要回归的两件事，他关于多神论心理学的很多看法都在试图做到这一点。你能谈谈这些东西在你的工作中吗，或者它们是如何出现的，如果你使用它们的话？是的，我的意思是，很难具体说。我在想我们是否，你知道，
I mean, with animism, I think I try and work with people, especially from not necessarily an external standpoint, but as far as internal phenomena, you know, always trying to understand what's happening to them as something that's alive, you know, so and you know, putting a face to the experience of depression, putting an image to the experience of addiction and, and letting it sort of amplify itself into something bigger. I think that to your point about ritual, man, we've lost it. And that's sort of the experience that I feel like people come up against again in the recovery space, which is the rituals. There's a famous quote, I forget by who, but it's the rituals remain long after the reason is remembered
我的意思是，对于万物有灵论，我想我尝试与人们一起工作，特别不是从外部的角度，而是就内部现象而言，你知道，总是试图理解发生在他们身上的事情是活生生的东西，你知道，所以，你知道，给抑郁症的体验一张脸，给成瘾的体验一个图像，并让它放大成更大的东西。我认为关于仪式的观点，伙计，我们已经失去了它。这就是我觉得人们在康复空间中再次遇到的体验，即仪式。有一句名言，我忘了是谁说的，但它是：仪式在原因被记住很久之后仍然存在，
or long after the reason is forgotten. So we just keep doing these things, but they almost feel empty. Ritual can be good and it can be bad. And it's just a religion when it's not alive anymore. And just like routine or tradition or, you know, there are 12 step programs, I think that are alive, that understand the concepts you're talking about. I mean, sometimes I tell people who think a certain way,
或者在原因被遗忘很久之后。所以我们只是继续做这些事情，但它们几乎感觉是空的。仪式可以是好的，也可以是坏的。当它不再活着时，它就只是宗教。就像常规或传统，你知道，我认为有12步计划是活着的，它们理解你谈论的概念。我的意思是，有时我告诉那些有某种想法的人，
I want you to go to this church on this day, because that's where you're gonna find your people. Whereas if you go at three o'clock, I don't's where you're gonna find your people, whereas if you go at three o'clock, I don't know that you will. Yeah, definitely. Definitely. And I think just, I think part of that is trying to push people to seek out ritual and to understand the importance of ritual in their life and then let them create it.
我希望你在这一天去这个教堂，因为那是你会找到你的同类的地方。而如果你在三点钟去，我不知道你会不会。是的，绝对。绝对。而且我认为，我认为其中一部分是试图推动人们寻求仪式，并理解仪式在他们生活中的重要性，然后让他们创造它。
I think that's part of the problem is people need to find space to develop their own rituals and find and attach meaning to them instead of being told this is the ritual you need to do. I think that works for a period, but really what we long for is a personal relationship to the way we move through life. And you know, the rituals that speak to say, my daemon might not speak to someone else's. And so a lot of the work I think that recovery in its next evolution will be about is helping people develop their own rituals versus putting them into old rituals, no longer working. Yeah.
我认为这就是问题的一部分，人们需要找到空间来发展他们自己的仪式，并找到并赋予它们意义，而不是被告知这是你需要做的仪式。我认为这在一段时间内有效，但我们真正渴望的是与我们生活方式的个人关系。而且，你知道，对我守护神（daemon）说话的仪式可能不会对别人的说话。所以，我认为康复在下一次进化中将涉及的很多工作是帮助人们发展他们自己的仪式，而不是把他们放入不再有效的旧仪式中。是的。
Exactly. Yeah. Well, that's beautiful. Is there anything that you want to say to wrap up? I want to be respectful of your time and not take you, you know, over your, over your lunch break. What, what all is, uh, anything that we don't touch on you feel like is important for, uh, or we have enough there to go ahead and, uh,
完全正确。是的。好吧，那太美了。你有什么想说的来总结吗？我想尊重你的时间，不想占用你的午休时间。还有什么我们没有触及的，你觉得重要的，或者我们已经有足够的内容可以继续，
release this on the internet and trust that people will reinstall the world without. Yeah. I mean, I think, I think what's important is we kind of said it all throughout is we're not saying anything bad about 12 steps or traditional recovery in that way. We're just saying that inevitably it does lack and what we need to find is where people can go in that moment or experience of lack instead of pushing back on them to do more
在互联网上发布这个，并相信人们会重新安装世界而不需要。是的。我的意思是，我认为，我认为重要的是我们自始至终都在说，我们并没有说12步或传统康复的坏话。我们只是说它不可避免地存在缺失，我们需要找到人们在那种缺失的时刻或体验中可以去哪里，而不是推着他们去做更多
work or putting them in a position where they feel like they're failing because something is awakening them and arising in them. And I think- It is not always the desire to use. Even if you tell them that, they may mistake it for it. But a lot of times it is dying of old things and a hunger for a new thing that we can't yet see. It's just the next, it's the next initiation.
工作，或者把他们置于一种让他们觉得自己在失败的位置，因为某种东西正在唤醒他们并在他们心中升起。而且我认为——这并不总是使用药物的欲望。即使你告诉他们，他们也可能误解它。但很多时候，这是旧事物的死亡和对我们尚未看到的新事物的渴望。这只是下一次，这是下一次启蒙。
It's the next moment in that person's development and then in that person's becoming. And I think that's the most important thing to think about in the evolution of what's coming is that how do we hold space for that experience? Thank you, that's beautiful. If people wanna find out more about what you do, I can include any link in the show notes,
这是那个人发展中的下一个时刻，也是那个人成长中的下一个时刻。我认为这是在思考即将到来的进化时最重要的事情，即我们如何为那种体验留出空间？谢谢，那太美了。如果人们想了解更多关于你所做的事情，我可以在节目说明中包含任何链接，
but what would you like them to check out? You know an article a book your your business on LinkedIn what would be a good thing? Yeah, they can definitely check out the LinkedIn profile and and from there, you know, they can check out You know, my website is depth recovery org and it sort of introduces Hillman to the recovery space young to the recovery space and has a bunch of writing and some general ideas of a different approach to this issue. Well, thank you. That's gorgeous. I will link to the LinkedIn page and then from there you can check out some of Corey's
但你希望他们查看什么？你知道，一篇文章、一本书、你在LinkedIn上的业务，什么会是一个好的东西？是的，他们绝对可以查看LinkedIn个人资料，从那里，你知道，他们可以查看，你知道，我的网站是depthrecovery.org，它向康复空间介绍了希尔曼，向康复空间介绍了荣格，并有很多写作和对这个问题不同方法的一些一般想法。好吧，谢谢。那太华丽了。我会链接到LinkedIn页面，然后从那里你可以查看科里的一些
other stuff. Thank you so much for getting on with us today. All right. Thanks, Joel. Hey, guys. This is Joel. And I wanted to pop in to remind you that we do this podcast for free, which there are a lot of expenses associated with one of the things that could help you and also
其他东西。非常感谢你今天加入我们。好的。谢谢，乔尔。嘿，伙计们。我是乔尔。我想插一句提醒你们，我们免费制作这个播客，其中有很多相关的开支，其中一件可以帮助你的事情，还有
would help us, as if you would learn about one of our sponsors, Hardy Nutritionals. I'm not a big fan of a lot of the BS and the wellness space. Hardy has randomized controlled trials on all of its products that they paid to be conducted by external researchers who found a lot of validity in what they do. One of the things that I like about Hardy is that they do double blind randomized controlled trials, which is the gold standard of research.
如果您能了解我们的赞助商Hardy Nutritionals，那将对我们有很大帮助。我不太喜欢健康领域里的那些废话。Hardy的所有产品都经过了随机对照试验，这些试验是由他们出资并由外部研究人员进行的，研究人员发现他们的产品具有很高的有效性。我喜欢Hardy的一点是，他们进行的是双盲随机对照试验，这是研究领域的黄金标准。
And they've shown that on top of a lot of health benefits, that mental health is improved and that especially in children with autism and ADHD, mood, anxiety, and symptoms of irritability were reduced, which is one of the things that traditional medication doesn't affect and often causes in order to enhance focus. So if you'd go to gethardy.com, that's G-E-T-H-A-R-D-Y dot com and use operacode taproot you'll get 15% off. There's also lots of information about all the ingredients and how they work on our website gettherapybirmingham.com
他们已经证明，除了许多健康益处外，心理健康也得到了改善，特别是在患有自闭症和多动症的儿童中，情绪、焦虑和易怒症状都有所减轻，而这正是传统药物无法改善，甚至为了提高注意力反而常会导致的问题。所以，如果您访问gethardy.com，即G-E-T-H-A-R-D-Y点com，并使用优惠码taproot，您将获得15%的折扣。我们的网站gettherapybirmingham.com上也有大量关于所有成分及其作用的信息。
and if you have any questions feel free to reach out to one of their wellness advisors. Hardy realized that the people who try their product like myself that weren't expecting much realized that it does make a significant difference and they stay on it for the rest of their life most of the time so if you enter the website you can schedule with a wellness advisor and get a customized plan made with a professional that Hardy pays for for absolutely free. I hope it works for you and if you have any questions reach out. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您有任何疑问，请随时联系他们的健康顾问。Hardy意识到，像我这样最初没抱太大期望而尝试他们产品的人，最终发现它确实带来了显著的改变，并且大多数人会终身使用。因此，如果您进入网站，可以预约一位健康顾问，并由Hardy付费为您制定一份完全免费的定制计划。希望它对您有效，如果您有任何问题，请随时联系。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。